let's go next to Connor from New Jersey
Connor from New Jersey welcome to the
program what's on your mind
um hey David I've talked to you a couple
times already appreciate you having me
on the show again I love it
um so I remember I called you a while
back um I saw the video you did where we
did like a snippet of our conversation
where I really didn't elaborate on what
was going on about with me coming from a
conservative space but again last time
was for me to say thank you for what you
do and you know I really find you
inspiring but let's move on from that
please um let's try to address like
where I'm coming from in like this weird
mix where I see myself as like socially
conservative and politically Progressive
right so I explained to you that like
I'm for gay marriage uh who support the
idea of LGBT rights and you know that we
should be able to see humans as humans
and not say like oh you're living a
dilution people should be able to at
least live their lives to the fullest
capabilities
so where I think that I might lean more
towards like uh more right-leaning take
is I'm for a free market to a degree
right I like the idea of small
businesses being able to freely compete
amongst one another but where I might be
more Progressive is where it comes to
corporations I feel like for them to
operate in a free market leads to small
businesses not being able to operate
freely as they would want to be in my
issue with corporations operating freely
is they have a tendency to smush
any ability for small businesses to
really freely operate and my argument
for this is like let's say you had this
small Ma and Paw shop those shops went
away when something like Walmart came in
which had much further stock had the
ability to out compete in terms of
products that they could sell they had a
much larger net worth than these small
businesses and a lot of them would end
up being bought up
because they just would receive the
money and be like well why am I going to
continue to struggle against Walmart if
I'm getting this money
I just kind of I'm not sure I really
understand
so you're saying on the one hand let me
see if I can understand the positions
you've outlined you you told me your
left wing on gay marriage and you are
progressive on corporations to the
extent that larger companies uh scoop up
or put out of business mom and pops but
you're generally speaking for a free
market and low business regulation which
makes you economically right-wing my
understanding the position is correct
yeah so I want the smaller businesses to
be able to operate more freely but I
think larger corporations should be
regulated to prevent them from corporate
monopolies being able to do things like
abuse offshore workers
um I mean a fine example would be in the
technological Industries we use
in the U.S I've learned it's not the
same case for other countries like
Germany but in the US there's a lot of
slave labor that takes place outside of
the United States yeah uh the Congo
would be a great example of that and my
whole point is more regulation I think
needs to be accomplished in order for
things like that to not be allowed of
U.S corporations yeah so I mean it's
really not there there's on let me I'll
give you two answers
in what you're telling me there is a bit
of a contradiction in the sense that
you're sort of espousing different views
about your expectations of government
depending on which issue we're talking
about like for example you support LGBT
rights but you're against governments
regulating businesses businesses that
might discriminate against LGBT people
no no but hold on I'm not saying you
said that I'm just saying that's a way
in which there might be a contradiction
but let me zoom out to the bigger
picture
in my view
saying that as a corporation once you've
reached a certain size there might be
additional regulations placed on you I
agree with that and I think that right
now that's a fundamentally left-wing
economic perspective and I don't claim
to be educated on this stuff but I was
trying to explain like you know I'm
still for small businesses being able to
do what they want but in a more
Progressive stance I don't think
corporations should be able to do what
they want considering and by
corporations you mean large corporations
right because well small businesses
might also be a corporation yeah
corporate monopolies I think is what I'm
really trying to get is a corporations
relatively left wing to me I mean it's
I'm not hearing anything definitively
right wing in there
um well again I I like capitalism I'm
not someone that thinks that capitalism
is inherently evil yeah just remember
social democracy which is the the
economic model of Denmark and Sweden and
other northern European countries it's a
form of capitalism it's well regulated
yeah there's like social democracy
there's social Democrats and then
there's Democratic socialists yeah
socialists who would want a capitalist
Society to become socialist inevitably
it would be Democratic socialists so I
guess in that sense yeah I would I'm for
social programs yeah no listen Connor
you're sounding uh you're sounding
pretty at least in 2023 for the United
States standard you're sounding sounding
at minimum Center left and uh always
good to hear how things are going
politically for you nice talking to you
David all right there it goes Connor
from Jersey sounding less and less like
a republican every time we talk